Hello ! que euh je pense 3e 4e vidéo peu
importe on embarquer directement et dans
le sujet aujourd'hui je l'ai parlé que
dans le monde des affaires souvent
bon se laisse emporter par notre
quotidien nos pensées nos réflexions
puis ça fait que il y a un
tu passes tes journées mais tu es tout
le temps en mode alerte tu es tout le
temps en mode réflexion tu es tout le
temps en mode résoudre des problèmes. tu
es un peu dans un chaos mental de
qu'est-ce que euh qu'est-ce que je fais
de ma journée fait finalement tu passes
tes tes journées, tu passes tes
semaines, tu passes tes années, tu
passes tes mois, peu importe pu au final
tu passes ta vie mais tu es tout le
temps dans ta tête. Donc tu vas aller,
tu vas avoir un souper de Noël, tu vas
avoir un dîner avec des amis, une soirée
avec ta blonde, ton ch peu importe, puis
tu vas quand même focus sur tes projets,
tes tes projets de business, tes ton
client qui s'est passé telle chose avec,
ton employé qui quitte, peu importe,
puis tu vas tout le temps penser penser
penser à ça. hyper toxique sur le long
terme qu'au final oui tu bâtis
mais tu es pas pleinement présent
tu es pas présent des choses que tu fais
ça fait qu'au final tu passes comme à
côté de ta vie parce qu'au final
l'objectif je pense c'est de bâtir c'est
toujours selon moi c'est de bâtir des
choses grandes mais en étant conscient
puis en étant présent puis en appréciant
la vie que tu mine
pu ça dans tous les moments
Donc c'est ça que je voulais parler que
je pense qu'il y a énormément de
personnes qui euh qui sont là-dedans,
qui sont dans la performance constante
mais qui prennent pas de moment pour
vraiment euh apprécier
puis d'être pleinement présent dans des
moments importants.
Donc ça je l'ai parlé justement ça mme
au premier sujet que je l'ai abordé,
c'était l'entropie psychique. Donc ça
c'est un chercheur si je me trompe pas
là je vais essayer de nommer son nom
Miami si Xen
peu importe d' point je nomme vraiment
pas bien son nom mais le concept dans le
fond c'est je vais la définir donc c'est
l'esprit humain tend naturellement vers
le désordre si aucune structure
consciente est imposée donc ça veut dire
que
par exemple si euh
tu laisses ta chambre par exemple On va
faire une analogie là. Si tu laisses ta
chambre puis tu clean jamais, tu as pas
de structure pour la cleaner, tu dis pas
il y a des des moments de la journée que
je vais la la ranger puis c'est dédié à
ça. Mais ta chambre naturellement de
jour en jour, de semaine en semaine,
elle va devenir dégueulasse, on est
d'accord tu sais, je veux dire, si tu la
pas, elle va devenir dégueu. Même chose
pour ton esprit. Si de plus en plus tu
avances dans tes jours, tes semaines,
tes années, ta vie, peu importe, il y a
plein de gens qui ont jamais pris le
temps de prendre soin de leur mental,
ben tu viens accumuler accumuler du
désordre dans ta tête puis ça vient au
chos. C'est là que ça mène peut
potentiellement à de la dépression, à de
l'anxiété constante
puis de toujours être justement en train
de réfléchir à des potentiels
problématiques.
Puis il y a quelque chose qui est une
solution à ça que je trouve que j'ai
commencé à pratiquer dans les dernières
années, que je trouve qu' aide
énormément pour au niveau euh
Oui. business, oui, le monde des
affaires. Oui. Euh tout ça, mais aussi
au niveau juste prise de risque puis
sortir de sa zone de confort,
c'est la méditation. la méditation,
sincèement, euh il y a beaucoup de gens
qui vont trouver que c'est weird, que
c'est euh quelque chose qui est réservé
justement au moins bouddhiste qui font
ça dans des temples puis qui sont en
position comme ça puis ils font des h
mais c'est euh
oui, c'est ça, mais c'est pas juste ça.
C'est au final c'est un entraînement de
l'esprit. C'est juste de au final de
concentrer ton esprit pour
l'entraîner
à être focus sur une chose.
C'est ça le principe de la méditation.
La définition, je me trompe pas de la
méditation, c'est
juste se concentrer sur une chose.
Si tu te concentres sur ta mé concent ta
respiration, tu médites. Tu te
concentres sur les sensations pendant
que tu marches, tu médites. Si par
exemple justement tu fais je sais pas
moi tu regardes un coucher de soleil
puis tu es pleinement dans le coucher de
soleil puis tu la regardes puis tu es
waouh c'est magnifique puis tu es en
contemplation puis il y a rien d'autre
qui se passe ta tête tu médites
tu parles à quelqu'un tu es full into it
la discussion les idées viennent on a
full une belle discussion puis tu es
pleinement dans discussion tu médites
c'est juste que souvent on médite pas on
va être en train de parler à quelqu'un
puis on va penser à 10000 l'autre
affaire qui pourrait euh qui qui
pourrait arriver dans le futur dans le
passé ou peu importe ça fait que tu
passes ta vie tu passes ta vie à pas
vivre le moment présent puis si on est
d'accord peut-être qu'on on va en parler
probablement dans une autre vidéo mais
que le moment présent c'est la seule
chose qui existe dans ta dans ta vie
c'est la seule affaire qui existe. La
seule affaire qui est importante dans ta
vie, c'est le moment présent. Le là en
ce moment, si tu passes ta vie tout le
temps en train d'attendre un autre
moment qui arrive plus tard, ben tu
passes tout ta vie. Donc ça l'important
de méditer, c'est de aiguiser ton esprit
à être focus sur une chose
puis d'être capable de l'apprécier au
maximum, de donner ton maximum à ce
momentl.
Donc
j' d'autres choses à dire à ce
niveau-là. Euh
puis
l'entrepreneuriat puis le monde des
affaires, c'est vraiment un monde où que
le brouillard mental est amplifié x 1000
parce que il y a pas de il y a pas de il
y a pas de punch puis de dépunch. Il y a
pas de moment où c'est que tu termes, tu
commences, tu termines. C'est tu es
constamment en train de travailler, tu
es constamment en train de résoudre des
problématiques. Fait si tu donnes pas à
ton cerveau, à ton esprit un moment où
c'est qu'il peut se dépuncher
puis il peut s'uncher,
ben tu es constamment en train de
réfléchir, réfléchir, réfléchir à des
problématiques, tout ça. Fait tu peux
passer ta vie à tout le temps penser,
tout le temps penser à euh à tes
problématiques.
Alors que par exemple si tu es salarié,
ben il y a un moment que tu vas puncher,
tu vas dépuncher fait que tu vas comme
te décrocher de ton travail puis le soir
tu vas pouvoir
te reconnecter en
mais l'entrepreneuriat c'est vraiment de
quoi qui
pousse vraiment à avoir un brouillard
puis un désordre mental
faut vraiment faire attention conscient
juste conscient c'est
Euh
puis là, j'avais quelques stat qui
disait que environ 72 % des
entrepreneurs vivent des difficultés de
santé mentale significatives versus 48 %
de la population générale. Donc vraiment
au niveau entrepreneurial, il y a
vraiment une hausse des personnes. Ça je
juste citer là, c'était dans le livre et
si l'entrepreneuriat rendez-vous de Den
Gagnon qui est un entrepreneur du Québec
que je l'ai cité qui c'est ça. Donc
vraiment, il y a une hausse au aux gens
qui
ne prennent pas soin de leur santé
mentale dont les entrepreneurs qui
doivent penser à 10000 choses
quotidiennement.
Donc ce qui mène à euh
ce qui mène à ce que je voulais aborder
qui est l'hygiène mentale,
donc vraiment de prendre soin de son
hygiène mentale, c'est pas quelque chose
qui est full full spirituel, full
intense. Puis il y en a ça leur fait
peur un peu de penser que c'est ah c'est
c'est de quoi c'est quoi spirituel puis
tout ça ? C'est de quoi qui est vraiment
c'est vraiment
scientifique dans le sens que
c'est très concret.
Plus que tu commences à méditer, plus
que tu te rends compte que c'est concret
puis qu'il faut prendre soin de sa santé
mentale. Autant on prend soin de son
corps, qu'on va s'entraîner, autant
qu'on va prendre soin de se laver le
corps
comme tu sais, tu as passé ta journée,
tu as travaillé, tu as travaillé
beaucoup, tu as eu chaud, ben tu vas te
laver le corps
avant d'aller te coucher. Mais c'est la
même chose pour la méditation. Tu
devrais faire la même chose, de le voir
de la même manière. Tu as eu une journée
full intense, tu as eu plein de
problématiques, plein de discussions,
plein de choses que il a roulé dans ta
tête. Ben à la fin de la journée,
faudrait que tu te laves la tête pour
être clean, pour aller te coucher puis
avoir une meilleure l sommeil pour que
le lendemain tu sois plus en forme,
ainsi de suite.
Donc ce qui mène à
ce que je voulais dire, donc si tuas
jamais essayé la méditation, je te
conseille au moins de l'essayer le
matin. Très simple, tu commences 10
minutes le matin. Donc demain matin,
commence, fais juste un 10 minutes.
Lève-toi pas 10 minutes plus tôt. Fais
juste t'asseoir sur un banc. Tu as pas
besoin d'être aché comme ça les jambes
croisées sur un banc le dos droit la
tête droite puis tu essayes juste de tu
fermes les yeux ess juste de te
concentrer sur ta respiration
juste de sentir l'air qui rentre dans
tes narines l'air qui sort de tes
narines ainsi de suite puis c'est sûr
que ta tête va partir. C'est sûr que tu
vas penser à 10000 affaire pendant que
tu tu fais ça, mais justement c'est ça
l'entraînement de l'esprit, c'est de
continuer à à sentir à à te focus sur
les sensations de l'air qui rentre,
l'air qui sort. Puis de même quand ton
esprit à part dans pleine direction, de
penser à plein affaire de ton client, de
peu importe, ben de oh OK, he je partir,
je reviens ma respiration. Ça se peut
que dans ton 10 minutes, ça se peut que
tu passes juste peut-être une de minutes
à être vraiment focus parce que le reste
est parti dans tes plein tes pensées.
Mais l'important c'est être conscient
puis de pratiquer ce revenir là à ta
respiration. OK ? Tu pars tu reviens, tu
pars, tu reviens pour que dans ta vie
quotidienne tu sois capable de passer de
business mental à on revient, on se
focus puis des calv sont au moment
présent.
Donc sur ce pass une excell journée.